I had to get certified like I I knew
there is no other option for myself
there was no pressure from my workplace
to get certified but it was just
personal accomplishment so my
certificate was the professional
architect however I'm mostly working
with machine learning tools but I wanted
to start with having the big picture
like I want to understand everything in
gcp even if it's not in depth I want to
know what's out there what what we have
now in our gcp in Scotiabank might be
different from what we're gonna have in
two years we might include other tools
it add more services on the roadmap so I
need to to understand what's how those
Services communicate connect and and
what are the challenges use cases
currently I'm studying for my second one
the machine learning one because it fits
right in my role